في شمال غربي سوريا افاد الدفاع المدني
السوري باصابه 190 شخصا جراء الزلزلين
الجديدين فيها تاي واضاف ان اغلب الاصابات
وقعت بسبب سقوطه حجاره او القفز من
الابنيه المرتفعه وتدافع وانهيار بنائي
متصدعين غير ماهولين ومئذنه مسجد في
جنديرس شمالي حلب الى جانب عدد من الابنيه
المتصدعه في خربه الجوز وحل حمزيه
غربي ادلب دون اصابات فيها كمنهارت جدران
وشروفات للمنازل في عده مدن وبلدات في رفي
حلب وادلب
من ادلب ينضم الينا مراسلنا ادهم ابو
الحسام ادهم كيف تبدو الصوره اليوم من
الداخل السوري بعد زلزالي ليله امس
نعم الخوف والهلع ما زال يسيطر على
الاطفال والنساء هنا في شمال غرب سوريا
جراز الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه البارحة
يعني نتحدث عن خوف لالاف العائلات التي
شاهدت ما فعله الزلزال السابق الذي ضرب
المنطقه في السادس من الشهر الحالي نحن
الان في احد مراكز الايواء الذي اقيم
مسبقا لواء عشرات او مئات العائلات
المتضرره جراء الزلزال السابق ولكن مع
حدوث الزلزال ليله امس زاد الضغط بشكل
كبير على هذا المركز وبحسب القائمين على
العمل الانساني هنا في مدينه ادلب لان
العائلات التي كانت تقطن هذه الخيام باتت
تشارك الان كل عائله باتت تشارك ثلاث او
اربع عائلات في خيمه الاطفال والنساء
يبيتون في الخيام والرجال
قضوا ليلتهم كامله على قارعه الطرقات وعلى
ايضا قرب المباني التي يعتقد انها امنه
نوعا ما حقيقه الوضع الانساني والخوف الذي
شاهدناه في عيون الاطفال والنساء البارحه
يعبر عن يعني صدمه كبيره لدى الاهالي هناك
حالات لقفز من الشروفات بعض من هذه
الحالات قضوا اضافه الى اصابات ايضا كثيره
وصلت الى المستشفيات في مدينه ادلب
والبلدات المجاوره لها تم وصولهم بحالات
انهيار عصبي غلبيتهم من النساء وغالبيتهم
ايضا من الشيوخ هذا المركز عباره عن 68
خيمه بقدره استيعابيه ل 68 عائله في
الحالات الاعتياديه ولكن بحسب القائمين
على هذا المركز الان يضم اكثر من
450 عائله بشكل كامل
العائلات هنا تحتاج الى كل شيء حقيقه
تحتاج الى الرعايه الطبيه تحتاج الى مواد
التدفئه ومستلزماتها اضافه الى الكهرباء
والمياه النظيفه من المفترض ان يكون
البارحه هو اليوم الاول في الدوام الرسمي
للدوائر الحكوميه والمدارس والجامعات ولكن
صباح هذا اليوم حكومه الانقاذ في شمال غرب
سوريا اوقفت الدوام دوام الطلاب ودوام
الجامعات وايضا الدوائر الرسميه خوفا من
الهزات الاعتداديه التي ما زالت مستمره
حتى هذه اللحظه حتى ان الكثير من العائلات
ايضا لا يستطيع العوده الى منازله والى
مدنه القريبه من هنا خوفا من هذه الهزات
التي لم تتوقف ابدا منذ ساعات الزلزال
الاولى في الثامنه تقريبا من مساء من مساء
البارحه نبقى معكم ان شاء الله في
المتابعه نرصد اوضاع العائلات ايضا حاله
العامه في شمال غرب سوريا
من ادلب ادهم ابو الحسن